ah
yeah i love the uh
i love milk
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by sebastian stan
he's an actor you know from his work as
the winter soldier in the marvel
cinematic universe i tonya political
animals and many more his latest
projects though are the much buzzed
about pam and tommy currently streaming
on hulu and his latest movie fresh which
is such release on march 4th likewise on
hulu sebastian stan welcome to the show
thank you man thank you i'm
thrilled to be here
how would you gauge your level of
comfort around spicy food as we get
ready to start
i don't know i uh i i certainly uh
haven't had a lot of spicy food in my
life
this is probably gonna be the the most
of it right now
okay great
all right
[Music]
okay
that's pretty good
so you play the role of motley crue
drummer tommy lee in the new hulu series
pam and tommy in episode 2 there's a
scene in which tommy is having this
heartfelt state of the union with his
own penis can you draw back the curtain
on the mechanics of shooting something
like that with animatronics and four
puppeteers it was an event i mean there
were cables and wires and
men pressing buttons and
directing uh it was um
probably just about as awkward as it you
know it can get um
kind of like a fight scene you know in
the sense that it needed to all be
choreographed and stuff but but the core
of the scene obviously is
very sweet because it's it's really
about a man realizing he's falling in
love with with a woman so
he's he's in a confessional kind of
state of mind growing up coming of age
yeah
more ways than one
[Music]
a little more
yeah
but still still nice
there we go i think i i say before i
regret
some cautions about how i talk about
your latest film fresh is i don't want
to give away any of the secret heinous
plot points but i do think that it's
safe to say that it's maybe your most
deliciously off the rails character to
date it's been a long time since i've
seen an actor seemingly have so much fun
playing an unhinged psychopath what is
it that you found cathartic about the
role of steve
it was kind of like
going down this weird rabbit hole of you
know studying a lot of these serial
killers and
um
i i sort of stumbled on this doctor
dorothy lewis
who has a great documentary out right
now called crazy not insane and then i
was able to reach out to her and talk to
her and she kind of helped me put the
whole thing together in a way and i mean
it's just funny that we're we're talking
about that movie over wings but
uh yeah actually it was it was you put
that in my head now yeah yeah
but the idea was that sometimes these
guys are so
weirdly relatable you know ted bundy was
like a very
charming guy i mean unfortunately that's
that's what worked for him for a while
so it's just it was just trying to kind
of
ground the character as much as possible
and you know drawing from different
serial killers in the past
all right sebastian are you ready to
move on here to the next wing sure
this one the clark and hopkins calabria
parking hopkins
just
sounds like a couple of explorers
that was great i think that was like my
favorite so far
reflecting on the 20 or so sets that
were built for the 2015 best picture
nominated film the martian which one was
the most jaw-dropping or impressive to
actually see in person
i think the facts that you have right
now are pretty impressive i'm like i
didn't know that
um
well look ridley scott i mean that is
just one of the greatest filmmakers of
all time and what was amazing about it
is like he would shoot with like 10
cameras
and so in his you know the the village
where you know he sits at the monitors
he would just sort of sit there with
these 3d glasses and you would have like
five plot plasma screen
tvs all you know each one for each
camera and the thing that that allows is
that
especially like we were shooting in the
middle of a storm you know we're
supposed to be in this sandstorm
and it's and literally you feel like you
are in a storm i mean it was
so immersive and and it just
when he shoots with so many cameras he
just allows you to kind of like be in
the scene 100 and that and i was like
this is never going to happen again
what distinguishes darren aronofsky's
process as a director you said of
working on black swan i had to not be
scared of him i just have this sort of
scene between these two guys you know
they go and they meet mila kunis and
natalie portman actually that that in
itself was kind of a scary scene i was
like we don't we need to make sure we
you know we we show up we know what
we're doing here you know but um
he had a whole character breakdown
written out for both of us and it's just
one scene in the movie and and you would
think
maybe that doesn't you know you just
come on and it's okay but he had a whole
history of how we got there to that
scene
what what our whole emotional life was
and and and just that level of
specificity i guess it's i was really
impressed with that what would you say
is the biggest difference between a fan
who recognizes you on the street from
your marvel work and the fan who
recognizes you from gossip girl
well gossip girl you know they're very
loyal to gospel fans i mean they really
have to you know like they've loved the
show they've
they've studied it they have wild
questions about that i mean it's just
interesting to me how i i still get that
once in a while but
you really have to go dig to sort of
find out about gossip girl but um their
loyalty yeah that's a good one
[Music]
let's see the phoenix
my god
[Music]
whoa
ah there it is
you knew it was coming
i was waiting
yeah just a subtle
time bomb
[Music]
ticking away
okay
so in a 2020 interview with the
hollywood reporter you had some very
insightful things to say about something
that i don't think a lot of casual movie
fans think about and that's acting in
the absence of dialogue what do you see
as the opportunity for an actor or maybe
what gets you most excited about doing a
scene in which there's very little lines
being spoken
i always think the audience is very
smart i just always think that you know
because when you watch movies or you
watch something you're always kind of
more drawn
i i think i don't know
or i find myself more drawn to to
the person who does less so so to speak
you know because you're we're always
trying to kind of understand what's
happening
and
i think when you
play a character that doesn't
um
that doesn't speak so much then um
it just gives the audience more of an
opportunity to kind of throw their own
ideas and projections on to the
character and then i think they get more
fascinated by that weirdly
but it's just also
interesting sometimes because we don't
often speak in life and we communicate
things even when we don't say anything
and and
sort of just that in itself might be
more
challenging sometimes
this phoenix
definitely crawling up my back
[Music]
this one this one's alright back in a
comfortable place exactly
i'm not i'm not drinking my milk until
you are whoa okay so we're in uh we're
in a little bit of a standard oh i don't
know i mean we'll see
nothing like whole milk to put some hair
back on your chest
all right sebastian we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context okay so
we'll put the picture over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story hmm
can you explain the origin story of this
stare down with the iron man mask and
what ultimately became of it yes this
was on the set of um winter soldier and
then they had that in a bag in the tent
there
and i was like i gotta take this picture
and then i gotta go send it to kevin
feige
and see what he thinks and i i didn't
even know that he was
doing civil war at the time so
without knowing that that one day maybe
i was going to fight iron man seeing
through the tea leaves it was a crystal
ball yeah yeah or at least certainly
hoping
yeah
all right up next oh boy
can you pull back the curtain of what it
was like to attend the stage door manor
summer camp i understand that natalie
portman robert downey jr also alum
that's right no it's it's a great it was
a beautiful camp and it's still there
and it was such a great opportunity
because
um you know i really
it was the first time i met other kids
from new york that were
my age who were acting and and it sort
of uh i met my manager there who i've
been with for 20 somewhat years and
and that was like my first head shot and
i think they have that on the wall over
there the stagedoor manor summer camp
hall of fame yeah yeah yeah
yeah just really really thinking about
that gossip girl role in that picture
there do you remember any of the
productions that you did while you're
there i did yeah i we did i did grease
uh i had a grease sweet charity and on
the 20th century so they were all
musicals yeah wow and that's why they
hung you in the rafters there
jersey yeah all right sebastian how you
doing you ready to move on here to the
second half yeah i think so queen
majesty okay
the tiger
moving on tiger sick sauce
tiger tiger burning bright
[Music]
probably gonna have a salad tonight
okay
interesting
still hanging on there you're doing
great yeah you're doing
i found your podcast appearance
alongside screenwriter jacob krueger to
be a really interesting peek into your
reverence for writer's rooms and your
perspective as an entertainer in general
why in your opinion should every actor
take a screenwriting class and vice
versa
wow um i'm i'm so impressed you know
about jacob krueger um
he needs to watch the show
you're always as an actor trying to
figure out how to best use your time
when you're not working you know i've
always dabbled with writing and this was
a great course and it sort of sit pretty
pretty standard pretty simple way into
it
and then i i do feel like it teaches you
how to be a better actor as a result
because you're just sitting there kind
of breaking down script analysis over
and over again you're trying to figure
out how when you're writing something
you're actually going through
the thoughts that would lead to what
that line is or that dialogue or
whatever so it i feel like it helps you
and you start to know you know what what
scenes really matter or what you really
need or what you're trying to say
um so it definitely helps be careful oh
god yeah i got you
you're right
i got you
13 angry scorpions jekyll and hyde
the color too is
menacing yeah
[Music]
oh it sounds bad you can tell right away
oh yeah
oh [ __ ] it's got almost like a tangy
sort of sweet barbecue kind of vibe to
it and then
very disruptive with the sort of violent
pepper action that happens underneath it
all
what a way to describe it
yeah it's like
it's um of like an accident happening in
my house right now
yeah well let's take you back to happier
times do you have a most treasured
memory from the time that you spent a
year studying abroad at shakespeare's
globe theater in london who knows you
know so much
it's amazing
um
you know what mark rylance watching mark
rylance he was in um
richard ii
and
he was really good
um
i wanted to cry today so this will be
good
um
and um anyway
he was so fantastic
that
i still can't get over it how important
or unimportant do you think formal
acting training is for an aspiring actor
listen
it's very important to study and train
and work on your craft
um
you know vitamin d very important
as well
i have to take a sip of this it's all
right i'm glad that you're the one who
broke the seal you know
i did it
i did it oh
first time i had whole milk in about 20
years
anyway
it's yeah it's super important i think
you know theater especially
are you ready to move on to the next one
this is the bomb beyond insanity
well
all i know is that there's a word on it
that said
caution
[Laughter]
hmm
oh
back to the
yeah i love the uh
i love milk
so my dad who's literally never texted
me about someone i'm interviewing ever
he wanted me to tell you that he thinks
captain america winter soldier is the
best marvel movie of all time and i
quote it advances character arcs not
just plot and it functions in part as a
political thriller with terrific fight
scenes it's a kick-ass superhero movie
what would you say discerns a kick-ass
superhero movie from a generic one
i love your father
um
i think you need good character
development
plot
and uh
milk yeah you definitely need milk plot
character
um
and um in milk and good good action
sequences uh to
break up
the pain
have you given any more thought to uh
the travel show the destination travel
food show that you'd want to do with
your mcu co-star anthony mackie yeah
yeah what would be the first location to
go to to shoot the pilot
we would go i would i really want to go
to japan
that'd be awesome personally
but uh
i don't know if i'll make it there
anytime soon
um
and um has he been on the show he has he
has been on the show actually he
probably got through these pretty well
he did he did of course he did
yeah i always thought he and i should do
a traveling show maybe we will
and you know what if you need a home for
it this is where we start this is where
we start right
you're doing great sebastian i know
you're going through it but you're doing
great are you ready to move on to the
next wing
pucker butt pepper companies
mean green
okay
yeah well
so much for uh
so much for
eating tonight
oh wow
i don't know if you saw jimmy kimmel but
should have kept those steel balls
you left him on his desk i did
could have brought times like these
um
but anyway
what are the fun facts you have over on
that table well you know what i was
intrigued that when your acting career
took off you avoided that sort of
entertainer reflexive impulse to move to
hollywood saying of new york that you
find it more grounding while la is not a
good compass
i did say that
well i guess it's to each his own right
but i grew up in cities all my life
and so i i just i thrive off that
impulsive experience
you know kind of
being able to
um
sort of live in the moment
and not um you know
plan everything
can you speak to the special personal
significance of the west side highway to
you oh i do love the west side highway
god what
do i talk about all these things
publicly why
um
i do love the west side highway i i you
know i've just i go running there and
i've been in there in tears i've been in
it you know i felt like through
a lot of different times in my life you
know it's like
for some reason i don't i don't know
it's just like my my happy place your
backbone your foundation the west side
highway it's always been there for you
oh yeah
all right
okay
yeah
what a ride what a ride it's been
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
viva la vida loco
living that life and look at us taking
on the wings of death making it here to
the end and just one more question
before we put you out of here in a
wheelbarrow full of crushed ice we've
talked at length about your movies but
before we go i think it's important to
acknowledge your love of astronomy and
you even interviewed astronaut scott
kelly from the international space
station while it was in low orbit
i did to close things out
what is the recent discovery ufo
sighting or space fun fact that
fascinates sebastian stan the most
oh i've always been very fascinated by
the idea that we could
colonize mars
you know
i think i read somewhere that if you got
a bunch of
satellites the size of football stadiums
and you put them around mars
you can melt the ice and then there
would be water and then we could live
there maybe
and so when i was a kid i was like
really obsessed with mars and i would
just always read up on mars and that's
just one thing that comes to my mind um
but
in case you haven't seen don't look up
you should
mark riley it's bringing it full circle
here yeah and we're all gonna die
but here we are fun fact sebastian stan
making it through the hot ones gauntlet
taking out a glass of milk and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you sebastian stan
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
after this lunch not a whole lot
um
but i uh
this is very fun and um anyway
tune in to see uh fresh on march 4th
or pam and tommy as it's currently
playing
and um
thank you for having me and and and
knowing so much
about knowing more about behind it
you're the best
dude it's so funny i mean this is like
it's like you don't think that it's
really gonna impact like
anything but it does
you're like weirdly high you know
it's so great thank you guys for having
me
[Applause]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
we've read the comments we've seen the
emails and after six years more than 250
episodes we can now bring you the full
hot ones experience in one convenient
package i'm proud to introduce you to
hot ones boneless chicken bites
available exclusively at walmart and
walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]